[موسيقى]
أجنبي يقول ما يفكر فيه ولا
أخفي حقيقة أنني لم أكن معجبًا
بقضايا شخصية رئيسنا السابق
ولست أيضًا معجبًا
[موسيقى] ،
لذا فهمت أنه لدي
القليل  الأشخاص الذين لا يحبونني
كثيرًا وأنا آسف لذلك لكنني
عبرت عن رأيي لأنني أعتقد أنه صحيح
أجنبي
كان السلوك مخزيًا وخاطئًا
لمصالحه الشخصية لا
تتقدم على مصالح رئيس هذه الأمة العظيمة
[موسيقى]
كان ترامب يعرف الحقيقة ،
فقد سمع ما قاله له جميع خبرائه وكبار
موظفيه أنه يعلم أنه
خسر الانتخابات ،
لكنه اتخذ قرارًا متعمدًا
بتجاهل المحاكم
لتجاهل وزارة العدل
لتجاهل قيادته الانتخابية
وتجاهل كبار مستشاريه ومتابعته.
جهد غير قانوني تمامًا
لإلغاء الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
لم يكن هناك أبدًا أي شخص
يمثل تهديدًا أكبر لجمهوريتنا من
دونالد ترامب ، لقد حاول سرقة الانتخابات الأخيرة
باستخدام الأكاذيب والعنف لإبقاء
نفسه في السلطة  بعد أن رفضه الناخبون